[موسيقى]
لا يوجد شيء مثل
قضية جنائية من بطولة سلام دنك وهذا صحيح بشكل خاص
عندما يتعلق الأمر
بخدع الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب ومطاردات الساحرات
وكانوا
يحاولون فعل أي شيء في
وسعهم لإيقافنا أولاً قبل أن تبدأ أي قضية
للمحاكمة ، سيتعين عليها النجاة من
الاقتراحات القانونية للتخلص منها ، فهذه مطاردة
الساحرات التي كانت مستمرة منذ فترة
طويلة ، حيث قاموا بتحويل العدالة إلى سلاح
في بلدنا إذا خسر ترامب تلك
الاقتراحات ، يمكنه محاولة الاستئناف الذي قد
يستغرق شهورًا إذا  ينجو المدعي العام من
تلك الطلبات بالرفض ، ثم تصل إلى
العقبة الثانية ، وهي أن المحلفين الذين يمثلون هيئة المحلفين
هم بشر عاديون يتم اختيارهم عشوائيًا
من عامة الناس حتى لو
تمت محاكمة قضية في جزء من الدولة حيث
لا يتمتع ترامب بشعبية كبيرة من الناحية الإحصائية.
من المحتمل جدًا أن ينتهي بنا الأمر مع واحد
أو أكثر من ناخبي ترامب في هيئة محلفين مكونة من 12
شخصًا تم اختيارهم عشوائيًا ،
وأعلن الليلة عن ترشيحي لمنصب رئيس
الولايات المتحدة ، كما أن ترامب
مرشح رئاسي حالي وتوجيه
الاتهام إليه أو حتى إدانته لا
يمنعه من الناحية القانونية  من إدارة قاضٍ
سيطلب من المحلفين تنحية
آرائهم السياسية ومعتقداتهم الشخصية جانبًا ،
لكنني أعرف في أيامي
كمدعي أن المحلفين بشر
وليسوا روبوتات يخضعون
لنفس التحيزات العاطفية والحوافز
التي يواجهها أي شخص  سيكون
والعائق القانوني في المحاكمة أعلى بكثير
مما هو عليه في هيئة المحلفين الكبرى للحصول على
لائحة اتهام من هيئة محلفين كبرى ، حيث
يتعين على المدعي العام فقط إقناع
غالبية المحلفين أنه من المرجح أن يكون
ترامب قد ارتكب جريمة
ولكن في المحاكمة  يجب على المدعي العام
إقناع هيئة المحلفين بالإجماع وما وراء
الشك المعقول ،
يعني وجود محلف معارِض واحد أن القضية هي محاكمة خاطئة
نتيجة كارثية للمدعين العامين حتى
لو كان هناك إدانة ، فنحن نصل إلى
العقبة الثالثة ، فليس من المؤكد
أن القاضي سيحكم على ترامب بارتكاب جريمة.
السجن سيعتمد هذا بالطبع على
مدى خطورة الجريمة ، لكن للقضاة
سلطة تقديرية واسعة جدًا فيما يتعلق
بالحكم على شخص ما بالسجن
والمدة والرابعة ، وفي النهاية حتى إذا
أدين ترامب وحُكم عليه
بالسجن ، فلديه الحق في استئناف
القضية.  يجب أن تؤيده
محكمة الاستئناف ، ثم من المحتمل أن تكون المحكمة
العليا وكذلك لائحة اتهام ترامب
لحظة تاريخية هي الأولى في
تاريخ الولايات المتحدة ، لكن النتيجة النهائية
للقضية بعيدة كل البعد عن كونها أجنبية معينة.